I went to search Leroy's friend and my
colleague went to search Leroy and as I
went to move over I saw Leroy pool hang
on out of his waist
and then leeway pointed a gun at me and
told me to disappear and literally as
I've turned in Leroy's fired another
shot which hit me about a centimeter
from a spine went through the top of my
kidney and out the side all I wanted to
do was Escape if I don't get away and
the rest of the police come I'm dead
for sure
I grew up in South London Clapham I grew
up with my grandmother and my uncles and
aunties my mother got murdered when I
was two I was uh
born in the village in Kent
Village called Paddock Wood
um came from a very religious background
my dad was a Baptist minister so
the way we were brought up was literally
by The Ten Commandments obviously I
wanted to um
fit in with my
my friends
and I just wanted to get a job as soon
as I can I had good opportunities I went
to a very good school I didn't make the
most of those opportunities and I left
at 16 just worked in the factory to get
a job and get some money
and I just wanted to get a car and have
a girlfriend
so um that's what I did I decided I
wanted to um move out of home and um
do something different in life and
that's why I joined the police
my early years all of my peers
were
Street people armed robbers
and
drug dealers I left school when I was
13.
and
started smoking cannabis and dealing
with petty crime and it just escalated
from there so I started doing Street
robberies
and then burgling
in the countryside instead of locally
and then this led to coming up cross
shotguns and firearms
and
then those started to be used to do
robberies I got moved to Brixton from
South Nord it was
um
similar crime but it was going on uh
higher volume in a much smaller area and
the open drug dealing
um
yet went on in South north but it wasn't
as open as it was in Brixton literally
the hated towards police it wasn't a
dislike it was it was it was almost a
hatred that you felt
was it scary
um I think policing can be scary
wherever you work
um but certainly the the confrontation
um was graded and where I'd worked
before
I remember
um when something had happened between
the black community and the police and
we got sent on to this estate just
literally just to go and check out a
stolen card have been recovered and it
was basically a setup for us to get
attacked yet about 100 people like
surround us and started throwing
missiles towards a car
um Frank windscreen got totally damaged
um but
um we were quite lucky really because a
lot of reinforcements were close by
on the flip side of that um
growing up was your kind of perspective
on the police
from early
we had a bad
Outlook
towards police because you're ingrained
in that Society is
ingrained in you from early
not to trust police one time one of my
cousins I remember when I done a
burglary and I was wanted and police
came to my house and the whole house
said I'm not in even my granddad's an
old man and he knows to say he's not
here where you want yeah and one of my
little cousins he just didn't know no
better in it and he said you're looking
for Leroy and the policeman said yeah he
said he's a new teeth no Tierney he's in
the cupboard he's in the wardrobe and he
runs I opened the door and I said shut
up and it was too late you understand
the policeman came in and I got arrested
and I kept from then I called him a
grass because I just couldn't help it
because it's ingrained on you
so one of my
uh
Young
people what was around me at the time
I sent him to Brixton to go and collect
some money from someone who was a friend
who had a couple of thousand pounds for
me for drugs what I'd laid on to him
and
I gave him some more to give to the
person he went there gave them more
drugs and didn't collect the money it
wasn't an issue the guy wasn't gonna rob
me or nothing but that's not what I told
him to do and I was a bit pissed off so
when he came back and he didn't have the
money I decided to go there myself
and
got my friend to take me on the back of
his bike so I jumped on the back on my
friend's bike
and we flew down to Brixton I was on a
late shift it wasn't anything at the
ordinary normal late shift always busy
that's with a younger colleague and um
we decided that uh
we could do with a little bit of
overtime which was so easy to get and
one of the places we went to uh was
there was a pub called the Atlantic Pub
and basically if you saw somebody
walking Wonder at a pub and out the
other
door
um
within 30 seconds or a minute you knew
they'd um they'd bought drugs so it's
easy to justify a stop and search and
um
we decided to do that but
what happened was we got overtaken by a
motorbike it was two up
and the pillion which was Leroy got off
and went into the pub
and
we didn't think a lot of it but the bike
then went off for a red light so again
we're no match for a powerful motorbike
so we just went around the corner and um
then we saw the rider
um Stu had his crash helmet off and he
he saw us and his body language just it
just wasn't right he was he was up to
something
I had a zigzag pistol in my waist which
I was walking with every day
and went to the pub went inside
to create the money for my friend
saw him got the money then he told me
that there's police in the Public's
World took do what I'm doing on gold so
I've come out the pub and I've said to
the person I was with come let's go
he started talking to some guy and I'm
saying to him let's go brother and then
the Sierra came back round
and that's when it all started
basically we um we parked up just
further along
um
and got out and we just um said look
we've seen you in the drugs Pub
um
there's no current keeper on the bike or
something I don't know if you mentioned
that now but take crash how much else we
can search for drugs as we started off
it wasn't anything out of the ordinary
but then get to a stage where you almost
over step that line and the whole
atmosphere just completely changed I
can't say what it is it's just changed
and you knew I knew we'd gone too far
and something was up
um but you can't you can't re retract
what you've just done so I went to
search Leroy's friend
um and my colleague went to search Leroy
and um
my uh the person I went to stop drop
saying on the floor which I thought was
cracked I don't know or never will know
um and I went to push him against the
wall to retrieve it and as I did that I
could see in the corner of my eyes that
Leroy was struggling with my colleague
and they were both on the floor
um and um then literally I'm going to go
and help my colleague okay that the
drugs and that that's not important my
colleague he's important yeah um and as
I went to move over I saw Leroy pool
hang on out of his waist it hit my
colleague in the leg
um the shot was fired it broke his leg
and then leeway pointed a gun at me and
told me to disappear and it's literally
um almost like slow motion
um you know this isn't happening yeah
the alarm's gonna go off in a minute
what do you do and literally as I've
turned in Leroy's fired another shot
which um hit me about a centimeter from
a spine went through the top of my
kidney and out the side
um and then I um
I managed to
um
find some protection by a van and
and then the next thing is I hear
another shot which I don't know where it
was fired at that time and then
eventually the motorbike went off and
they they drove off
for me it was a case of and when
something traumatic happens where you
get involved in something traumatic what
what we train in the places you've got
to be positive yeah I'm going to live
I'm going to live I'm going to survive
and that came through with me is that I
can remember still to this day thinking
I'm not dying here I'll die in hospital
but I'm not dying here and um that just
sort of kicked in with me
um
and I know it did my colleague at the
time as well
when
all this
unfolded I was wanted for escaping from
prison so
all I wanted to do was Escape I just
wanted to escape and it was fight or
flight and
I talk the wrong decision to just
fight you know no second four or
anything it was just all fast
and it just all happened and the final
shot was in the air
if I don't get away and the rest of the
police come I'm dead
for sure because everyone can be mad as
hell and
I couldn't afford to get arrested in
those circumstances I'd committed myself
so that's basically what happened
at that stage of my life I wasn't
friends with no police or got any
empathy for police or anything to do
with
how anyone felt apart from I don't want
to get nicked and I'm not guy in prison
so I was just making good my Escape
and I had people ringing me every two
minutes
you need to leave you need to leave you
need to leave I'll turn on Italian it's
on the Telly it was just on top do you
understand yeah like fully on top and
then I swapped pistols and went to a
little secreted kind of like a little
out of the way very poor and took a
ferry to Holland
James and what injuries had you
sustained and what happened to you
straight after
I went to uh
King's College Hospital
um
and I was there I was in there for four
days
and then I'd uh because I was shorter
beds even in those days I had to go back
every day to have the wound dress
and I was off work for six months
um
and then I went back to work and I went
back to Brixton and I went back onto
Frontline duties which obviously
wouldn't allow you to do nowadays but
that's how it was then and I always felt
that um
um yeah I had to go back and do it or I
was I'd never be able to do it and it's
one of the hardest things I've done in
my life
but one of the best things
um I never I never hated Leroy at the
time I knew I was in the wrong place at
the wrong time or I look at it at the
right place at the right time to
somebody
um
didn't get injured or worse
you look back now and Leroy could have
just fired a shot in the air and we
would have disappeared you know
um
but um you know hindsight's brilliant
and also from my point respective is
that Leroy had the time had the means to
kill us both
um and he didn't
so
um
there's a lot of different ways of
looking at it like that and I was quite
thankful and grateful that my injuries
weren't as bad as what they they could
have been and Simon's was was worse than
me but
even then it could have been worse
I escaped Holland I was over there for a
little while and obviously it's a
different language and I never had the
right connections and that so I wanted
to get back to somewhere where I could
move where I could function so I
couldn't go back to Jamaica because I
was wanted over there for something else
and they had people in America so
they're saying to me yeah go to America
and you can link up with them so I went
to New York and then I linked up with
some Jamaicans in Connecticut
with some Jamaicans what was in a
10-year war with some other Jamaicans
Rats on cats they call themselves so
the last person would come down there
before me he'd been seen by the other
side and the next day he went to the
restaurant to buy something to eat and
the other side saw him and slapped him
straight Gone Dead and his ex on the
floor where they shot him so that was
like
that was like a memorial sign for for
him because that's what happened to him
and he was only in the in the place for
one day and that's the environment that
I was living in and then basically
I had some girls come from England they
was living in my condo with me and one
of them started smoking crack in my
house and I I'm telling her this can't
work because the guys what I'm rolling
with they're anti-drugs not weed but
crack and if they think that I'm smoking
crack in the house
I'm gonna become a liability and they
might decide to just
shoot me in the back of the head I'm
from in the dumpster and take my money
and my jewelry and my whatever I got
because they know I'm wanted
that's not going to come out of that so
I wound her and then she never listened
and started smoking in the house again
and
basically
I took her to a train line to to
basically kill her so we got to the
train line and she just knew she had to
run for her life so she'd come out the
car and she just ran it was a one-way
Road I did fire some rounds none of them
touched her and she just went straight
across the road nothing the traffic
nothing is like a miracle she just went
straight across and just disappeared I'd
never seen nothing like it she ran
straight to the police she went straight
into a hospital screaming screaming and
then all of the people what she coming
into contact which is saying yes this is
that he shot you please once he said
that that was it was over
they got FBI SWAT team and they come for
me
I was in the house wanted to get some
oil
they said
that me and one man should go and get
the oil so I had a Mac 11 on me the guy
had a chief silver Magnum
and we've come out of the condominium
I've took a left to come out to go to
the supermarket I just saw FBI sort team
around the car don't move [__]
don't move don't move I got you I got
you I'm gonna blow your head off and
everything just stopped in that second
and then they took me out of the car
this Army slapped me up bang my head in
the car Bonnet and yeah reality kicked
in from there
they charged me with possession of a
factory situation
two tier cracks 62 weed
or something along them lines and
possession of Mac-11 and
other firearms and I had to uh
agreed to come back to England for them
charged to be dropped so I went back to
England and then I got 67 years
four
attempted murder
on James and then I got 14 years
for armed robbery and then I got five
years for
unlawful shooting and I got two years
for escaping from prison so 67 years
back run concurrent you do 25.
and I did 17 years
three months out of it
and um James did I suppose when you
eventually found out that Leroy had been
arrested
how did that feel
um
all the time he was free it was
obviously I was I was a little bit
paranoid always looking over my shoulder
looking out for unusual cars in the
street I couldn't really relax at all
um
and um yeah it was a relief as well
um my view on the sentence was yeah he
deserved it you got what he deserved
um again hindsight now look back and
Louisa 17 years out of 25
whereas most most prisoners would serve
about half
so certainly he served for me I felt
that he'd served his time again that was
later on in life I felt that it it had
served his time as as a cat double a and
a prisoner
um
and I I did field it for myself and
everything I spoke about earlier that
the Justice had been done
the first time I got released I remember
coming in the garden in in uh the hostel
and seeing squirrels and all that and
getting blown away just thinking wow and
oh it's the boss and Sainsbury's where
the machine was talking to you and lots
of stuff it was like unbelievable and
then I was getting lots of pocket money
given to me from all all directions and
after about three months of all of that
I started slipping back into the only
things that I kind of knew so I got
arrested again for conspiracy
and
I was so lucky I got not guilty on that
trial and then was released again so I'd
done another two years so that's 20
years altogether now I said to myself
I'm gonna write a book because I've got
a lot of stories and a lot of things
will have happened to me and I can write
a book and let some young people
understand what doesn't make sense or
what makes sense and what's not away
from what is the way
and basically
when I wrote the book
it came out and it had a good reception
and then that started my transition to
understanding another way of life and
looking at things different and going to
schools to talk to young people and then
that's how
me and James would to end up being
connected
in real life now
because James read my first book and
basically I had a victim Support Officer
all the time Leroy was in prison just
updated me where he was what he was
doing
um some of what was his conditions were
and um she uh she was really really good
and she just said that it got this book
out and you know
um but it was called in that and so I
bought a copy and I read it and I read
it a couple of times and um
the thing that really stuck out for me
was the honesty you know there was no
ball in it at all it was just all all
honesty and
you know it's um
it just makes you realize what a
a violent background and a violent life
that Leroy was involved in which
obviously as a police officer you have
some understanding
but you don't always have the full
understanding of it and that's certainly
something since I've been friends with
Leroy that is really
um
put that brought that point home to me
and especially like life in prison it's
not something you really know much about
as a police officer and but now I've you
know a lot of things that have gone on
that Louise told me about is um
yeah you know I would never have known
if I'd have not met him
if he does want to go
the baked good out of his life then I
just felt that some of the best moral
support he could have would be from one
of his victims
um so
I sent an email to the publisher in a
book who passed it on to Leroy and then
we exchanged emails a couple of times
because obviously there's a lot of
distrust from both sides and rightly so
and then eventually we met up at um
Cherry cross railway station it was an
opportunity for Leroy to to apologize
and I just wanted to meet him just um
out of interest to see what it was like
as a person
not as a gangster as a person
um and so you have to look beyond what
he was doing what he did at the time and
um unfortunately in what Leroy's been
involved in in his life he's the true
person
has never really come out until now
you can't show any act of kindness or
weakness as a drug dealer or a gangster
because you're finished you've got to be
strong and then you've got to be
stronger and stronger and more ruthless
and more ruthless otherwise you you're
finished I I get the cynics all the time
about yeah he's just doing it for show
he's not genuine and all that but I can
tell them he's genuine yeah you know I
was police officer for 30 years yeah I'd
be a mug if I didn't believe
what I've seen
the change that I've seen in Leroy and
it's not it's not just me forgiving
Leroy Leroy's had to
want to change and the Temptation for
Leroy to go out there and make loads of
money selling drugs is there now for him
yeah and um to not do that is that takes
a strong a strong person
and um
as Louisa says he's not going that way
I've been out now for 10 years or just
over 10 years and
yeah I got my two dogs and I just live a
normal life and I'm happy to be in that
situation
and Leroy just going back to the moment
that um James forgave you I suppose what
did that mean to you and and how has
that impacted your life
it's been a powerful thing because
as I said before
James is the only person the first
person to ever do something like that
and
even me
when I think about it
it would be hard for me to to
I don't know man
I've been through a lot of stuff now I'm
looking at things like because of what
James has done I would have to forgive
someone if they'd done something to me
but it doesn't it goes against the grain
of what I know and what I was grown up
to so I was like shocked and humbled by
it and I still am yeah but it's it's a
beautiful thing
and I'm grateful
you get me I'm grateful
what I've learned from this is is
um
showing empathy putting myself in
Leroy's shoes the way he was brought up
his mum being murdered
what his peers were like
um and and I look at it and I think
could I have gone straight in those
conditions
if I was Leroy and the Arts would
probably know and I had the
opportunities and I didn't take them but
I I did make the most of
um of opportunities later on in life
when I joined the police
um
but for me it's about understanding what
other people might be going through not
just thinking about yourself
um and I think that that's lacking in
society nowadays that we it's all about
us it's not about it's all about me it's
all about us it's not about what other
people what they go through what they
might be experiencing
um and that's something that I've you
know I can't say enough that young
people could learn from that
we've got our own friendship what is
as good as it could be in this world
what we're living in that's the way I
look at it and I'd if like if I had to
put myself In Harm's Way I would put
myself in arm's way for him
a million percent
because I feel like I would have to
because what he's done is so huge
so that's what it is for me
[Applause]
I remember Thriller coming in the middle
of the road machine gun
Bounce has been hit straight in the head
standing next to me I just remember all
the little youngsters like standing over
his body jumping over the bar